[Música]
un código rojo para la humanidad un
nuevo informe del grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático expone que es
inequívoco que la actividad humana es
responsable por el calentamiento global
el documento apunta que la temperatura
del mundo podría cruzar el nivel de los
1.5 grados de calentamiento en los
próximos 20 años mucho antes de lo
previsto tenemos análisis en esta misión
y el avance del talibán en afganistán no
cesan este lunes el grupo capturo la
sexta capital provincial en menos de una
semana la situación se presenta al
tiempo que en las últimas 24 horas se
han registrado combates en 13 de las 34
provincias del país mientras las
negociaciones de paz continúan
estancadas
entró en vigor el pase sanitario en
francia para asistir a bares
restaurantes y para viajes internos y de
larga distancia el documento certifica
la vacunación una prueba negativa de
menos de 72 horas o haber superado
recientemente el hobbit 19 esto a pesar
que miles de ciudadanos se manifestaron
durante semanas en contra de la nueva
normativa
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
en france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez
y es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos el
informativo hablando del más reciente
reporte climático de naciones unidas que
expone que la actividad humana es
responsable del calentamiento de la
atmósfera los océanos y el suelo del
planeta
el documento calificado de código rojo
por el secretario general del organismo
antonio guterres destaca que algunas de
las devastadoras consecuencias del
calentamiento global son irreversibles
para analizar este tema conectamos con
piedad martín ella es directora regional
interino del programa de naciones unidas
para el medio ambiente en américa latina
y el caribe señora martín gracias por
acompañarnos el reporte indica que el
calentamiento global podría superar 1.5
grados incluso diez años antes de lo
previsto qué implica esto para la
humanidad
buenas noches bueno el cambio climático
ya está afectando todas las regiones de
la tierra como muestra el informe pero
lo que experimentan las personas es muy
diferente de este promedio mundial por
ejemplo en el ártico el calentamiento
está siendo más del doble de este
promedio de 1.1 que ya estamos
analizando y reportando el informe
analiza el aumento del nivel del mar el
incremento de la frecuencia intensidad
de eventos extremos como huracanes olas
de calor sequías incendios la
degradación de suelos extinción de
especies y el aumento de este
calentamiento lo que va a producir es
exacerbar esos cambios que estamos
viendo ahora va a haber más olas de
calor se alargarán las estaciones
cálidas y se aportarán las estaciones
frías pero si superamos el 1.5 grados
podemos tener episodio 2 por ejemplo de
calor extremo que al que alcancen
umbrales de tolerancia críticos para la
agricultura y la seguridad humana habría
cambios en el ciclo hidrológico mayor
intensidad de lluvias e inundaciones
también más sequías en latitudes altas
probablemente aumentarán las
precipitaciones
otras disminuirán pero lo más importante
es que se nos acaba el tiempo para
planear y actuar eso es lo que nos está
diciendo también el informe la
información que presenta y puede servir
para gestionar los riesgos y prever cómo
nos vamos a adaptar pero puede que no
sea suficiente si seguimos impactando el
sistema natural y aumenta el
calentamiento bueno vemos un cambio en
el lenguaje que se usa en este reporte
porque ahora los señalamientos a la
responsabilidad de la humanidad son
según lo que se dice y me equivoco si
usted le estaba mencionando pero cuáles
son las medidas más urgentes por tomar
bueno el cambio en el lenguaje ha sido
muy importante porque no cabe duda que
han sido las decisiones que ha tomado la
humanidad y los hábitos los que han
desestabilizado el sistema climático
pero también es muy claro que la
responsabilidad sobre este problema
global es diferenciada entre los países
y las regiones así también los impactos
que son mayores en los países y
comunidades que tienen condiciones de
mayor vulnerabilidad entonces es un
mensaje que se debe asumir desde la
solidaridad y la corresponsabilidad las
políticas las acciones se deben centrar
en reducir la vulnerabilidad posibilitar
que los recursos que hay para la
adaptación se distribuyan de manera
equitativa y cumpliendo los derechos
humanos de todas y todos a menos que se
reduzcan las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero
el objetivo de no que no aumenten el
calentamiento global más del 1,5 grados
será inalcanzable entonces hay que
limitar a la quema de combustibles
fósiles y transitar rápidamente a
fuentes de energía renovables
a la vez también hay que asegurar la
estabilidad de los sistemas naturales
detener la deforestación la degradación
de los ecosistemas marinos
estos estos sistemas naturales son los
que almacenan y capturan dióxido de
carbono pero también son los que nos
están dando servicios fundamentales como
producción de elementos de agua y
protección frente a desastres en el
contexto además de la pandemia con la
crisis social y económica y sanitaria
hay que unir esfuerzos no hay espacio
para elegir entre uno u otro tipo de
soluciones creo que hay que aplicarlas
todas acelerar el cambio tecnológico
modificar patrones de consumo y
producción y desplegar masivamente
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza que
mantengan su estabilidad recuperen los
servicios de los ecosistemas pero
también aseguren que tenemos una
infraestructura verde resiliente al
clima para el bienestar humano y del
planeta pues señora martín muchísimas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france24
vamos ahora a afganistán donde el grupo
talibán capturó la sexta capital
provincial en menos de una semana
mientras continúan los enfrentamientos
con las fuerzas de seguridad afganas
a repeler a los insurgentes de las
grandes urbes el avance talibán se ha
visto fortalecido tras la retirada de
las tropas estadounidenses y aliadas del
territorio tras casi 20 años de invasión
y en medio de los enfrentamientos se
encuentra la población civil marina
sardenya nos amplia
civiles huyendo de sus hogares ciudades
sitiadas y destrucción vuelven las
imágenes de guerra a afganistán y la
endémica violencia e inseguridad crónica
durante los últimos 20 años el mapa de
control del país ha sido un lienzo en
constante cambio pero ahora con la
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses y
sus aliados llegando a su fin nuestra
misión militar en afganistán concluirá
el 31 de agosto más del 56% del
territorio está en manos de los
talibanes desde la ofensiva lanzada el 1
de mayo tras conquistar con relativa
facilidad las abandonadas zonas rurales
donde la presencia del gobierno es muy
reducida el grupo islamista se ha hecho
con el control de seis capitales de
provincias y están en enfrentamientos en
112 ciudades mientras las desmorona las
fuerzas de seguridad afganas intentan
frenar los ataques de camargo kandahar
las cargado afortunadamente la situación
de seguridad en las provincias de
kandahar las cargas herat han mejorado
las fuerzas de seguridad afganas se
están patrullando las ciudades el
enemigo ha sufrido grandes pérdidas
desde los años 80 los afganos han vivido
en permanente guerra
la reciente insurrección los talibanes
han sorprendido al no haber esperado la
retirada completa de las tropas
extranjeras una señal según apunta los
analistas de que se sienten fuertes
tanto el gobierno urbano los
observadores internacionales se muestran
pesimistas no sólo por el poder
armamentístico talibán sino por los
pactos con los señores de la guerra
locales que anticipan un avance mayor
del grupo los afganos tienen un dicho
los extranjeros tienen el reloj pero
nosotros tenemos el tiempo desde su
derrota en 2001 los talibanes han sido
conscientes de que las tropas
internacionales irían más pronto que
tarde
afganistán inicia así una guerra
infinita que tiene un solo perdedor la
población civil afgana
vamos a américa latina' el gobierno de
daniel ortega en nicaragua llamó a
consultas a sus embajadores en argentina
costa rica colombia y méjico esto en
reciprocidad por el llamado hecho por
esas naciones a sus respectivos
representantes en el país
centroamericano el hecho se produce en
medio de una ola de represión y arrestos
contra opositores de cara a las
elecciones de noviembre en las que
ortega buscará una cuarta reelección al
menos siete aspirantes presidenciales
han sido arrestados la llamada coalición
nacional de nicaragua un bloque
integrado por opositores pidió que se
desconozcan los resultados de dichos
comicios
en otras noticias en francia entró en
vigor la ampliación del pase sanitario
para entrar a lugares como cafés bares y
restaurantes en varias partes del país
los dueños de los establecimientos han
hecho cambios en sus locales para poder
aplicar la medida en parís la policía
controla que se cumpla la regulación que
genera molestias en parte de la
ciudadanía
los franceses ya no pueden disfrutar de
las terrazas de los cafés sin su pase
sanitario como estas varios lugares
comenzaron a requerir este lunes el
certificado digital
esta mañana colocamos nuevos carteles y
cordones para proteger la terraza para
que podamos controlar a las personas
antes de que entren por los adoquines de
la capital
ahora patrullas policiales controlan qué
bares restaurantes y otros lugares
culturales apliquen la regulación o con
wapa esta mezcla no podremos controlar
todas las terrazas pero efectivamente al
hacer controles aleatorios que se harán
a diario y que permitirán esperamos
pasar el mensaje con firmeza es el
mensaje directamente queremos convencer
al mayor número de personas para que
vayan a adornarse y que así puedan tener
un pase sanitario valiente a pesar de
que muchos franceses han aceptado la
medida otros la siguiente dando de
absurdo son sap suman facto esta acción
realmente no sé qué es esto estamos
sentados en una mesa al aire libre somos
dos no hay nadie alrededor es el
absurdistán digital
el pase también entró en vigor para los
viajes en trenes de larga distancia y en
trayectos interurbanos pondremos en
marcha controles masivos controles que
se realizan en el andén del tren como
pueden ver aquí en la estación de lyon
con una gran cantidad de personal
movilizado en los andenes también habrá
controles dentro de los trenes
aun cuando la medida desembocó en
multitudinarias manifestaciones todos
los franceses sin excepción deberán
hacerlo parte de su nueva realidad
y continuamos en parís tras concluir los
juegos olímpicos de tokio siguen
llegando a sus respectivos países los
atletas que lograron quedarse con una
medalla en las justas
la fiesta cobró especial relevancia en
la capital francesa que tomó el relevo
como sede de los próximos juegos en 2024
amal benotman nos cuenta los detalles
adios tokio
tras dos semanas de competición en la
capital nipona
los atletas regresan a sus respectivos
países donde son recibidos como héroes
es el caso de la mont marcelia coach en
italia quien ostenta actualmente el
título del hombre más rápido del mundo
también fue acogido con elogios del
atleta fabrice song o en burkina faso y
los representantes rusos también fueron
celebrados en la plaza roja de moscú
pero el retorno de los deportistas
olímpicos tuvo mayor significado en la
capital francesa próxima sede de las
justas
la alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo y los
últimos deportistas franceses que
compitieron llegaron con la bandera
olímpica oficializando así el traspaso
de los juegos de 2024
será el primer gran evento de verano
posterior al comité es un tema muy muy
importante para nuestro país esto
finalmente es una oportunidad increíble
para que nuestro país esté allí en 2024
porque nos ayudará a recuperarnos
después de estos años extremadamente
difíciles
los homenajes y las celebraciones se
concentraron frente a la alcaldía
parisina donde ya ondea la bandera
olímpica
la gente quiere vibrar quiere compartir
emociones muy fuertes solo el deporte
puede proporcionar eso francia tiene
todo para hacer juegos absolutamente
increíbles
vamos a cantar pruebas en sitios
icónicos encontraremos soluciones para
que los aficionados puedan conocer a los
atletas heridos la delegación francesa
obtuvo 33 medallas en tokio menos de las
esperadas
ahora el país tiene tres años no solo
para intentar mejorar su marca sino para
cumplir su promesa de unos olímpicos
económicos psicológicos paritarios y
abiertos a las masas en otras noticias
una de las presuntas víctimas del
empresario estadounidense jeffrey
epstein acusado de tráfico sexual de
menores presenta una demanda civil en
nueva york' contra el príncipe andrew
integrante de la realeza británica se
trata de virginia
quien asegura que el duque de york abusó
de ella cuando era menor de edad ya en
2019 la mujer aseguró que epstein la
obligó a tener relaciones sexuales en
tres ocasiones el príncipe ha negado la
acusación en una ceremonia discreta
nagasaki conmemoró el aniversario número
76 del bombardeo atómico que dejó más de
70.000 víctimas mortales en su mayoría
civiles líderes nipones hicieron un
llamado a la comunidad internacional
para lograr un mundo sin armas nucleares
los detalles en el informe de ariana
villacorta
un minuto de silencio a las 11 y 2 de la
mañana marcó el inicio de la ceremonia
que conmemoró a las víctimas del
bombardeo a nagasaki en el parque de la
paz en su aniversario número 76 el
alcalde de nagasaki alabó el tratado
sobre la prohibición de las armas
nucleares y se dirigió principalmente a
rusia y a eeuu por su poderío nuclear y
también por medio de la presente hago un
llamamiento a los líderes de las
naciones con armas nucleares y a los
países bajo sus paraguas nucleares deben
enfrentar la realidad de que el
pensamiento de que las armas nucleares
son necesarias para defender sus países
bajo la disuasión nuclear
en realidad hace del mundo un lugar más
peligroso coto
el ataque por parte de eeuu destrozó la
mitad de esta ciudad y dejó más de
70.000 muertos en su mayoría civiles sin
embargo el calor y la radiación que
produjo la bomba causó enfermedades como
el cáncer deformidades y discapacidades
en los sobrevivientes además de
trastornos y heridas psicológicas en
efecto japón reafirmó su compromiso para
crear un mundo más pacífico
como el único país que ha experimentado
un bombardeo atómico en la misión
inmutable de japón es avanzar hacia
adelante paso a paso en los esfuerzos de
la comunidad internacional hacia la
realización de un mundo sin armas
nucleares
la bomba atómica sacudió esta ciudad
tres días después del ataque a hiroshima
que desapareció el 70% de la ciudad y
mató a 140.000 personas el 15 de agosto
de 1945 japón se rindió poniendo fin a
la segunda guerra mundial
[Música]
llegamos al final del informativo a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos en
france 24
[Música]